Guidel c'est un formidable moment
d'échange et de débat sur l'ensemble des
sujets qui nous importe il s'agisse de
l'actualité nationale européenne ou
mondiale et des perspectives que nous
souhaitons dresser pour notre pays un
journaliste politique me disait au modem
vous êtes ceux qui réfléchissent le plus
avec l'ensemble de vos parties prenantes
de François Bayrou anoministes nos
parlementaires nos cadres et du locaux
évidemment l'ensemble des adhérents du
Mouvement Démocrate et puis l'idée bien
évidemment c'est aussi des moments de
convivialité autour du fameux pot des
régions et également autour de nos
villages et aussi autour des questions
de sport de culture et puis avec
quelques nouveautés que vous aurez
l'occasion de découvrir un Guidel et
puis Guidel c'est la famille c'est la
réunion de la famille sous le soleil de
la Bretagne Guidel c'est le 29 37
septembre et 1er octobre inscrivez-vous
vite sur
ur pour nous vendémocrate.fr et j'ai
hâte de vous y retrouver